لقد كنت في إيران للتو أمضيت أكثر من أسبوع
على الأرض ، أردنا التعرف على
طبيعة حياة الأشخاص الخاضعين
لهذه العقوبات وما يشعرون به
حيال الولايات المتحدة مع التوترات
بين البلدين الشديدة تحت وطأة
العقوبات ، هل أنت قليل  منزعج من قيام
أمريكا بفرض عقوبات على إيران ،
ما الذي تعتقد أنه لا تعتقد أنه من
العدل فرض عقوبات على الدول على
الرغم من العقوبات التي كان لها
تأثير مدمر حقًا على
اقتصاد البلاد ، فقد كانت العملة في
الأساس في حالة سقوط حر وأردنا
ذلك  احصل على فكرة عما يشبه العيش في
ظل هذه الأنواع من العقوبات ، لذلك
ذهبنا وزرنا متجرًا للأدوية على
سبيل المثال لمعرفة ما إذا كانوا يعانون من
أي نقص في الأدوية ، والتقينا
امرأة هناك أخبرتنا نعم لقد سمعت
عن حالات حيث  لا سيما
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالطب المتخصص جدًا ، كان من
الصعب جدًا على الأشخاص
الحصول عليه من السوق السوداء للأدوية ،
فلدينا سوق سوداء أخرى
لا تدعمها حقًا  قريب من غزة ولكن
أي شيء لا تجده في أي صيدلية
تجده
باهظ
الثمن ثم ذهبنا إلى مركز تجاري للإلكترونيات
وكان الأمر أشبه بكونك في عالم موازٍ
لأن العقوبات كان لها تأثير واسع.
فيما يتعلق بالاقتصاد ، لا يتمتع الأشخاص
بنفس القوة الشرائية التي
كانوا يتمتعون بها من قبل ، ولذا فقد تتمكن
من الحصول على أحدث إصدار من iPhone ولكن لا يوجد
الكثير من الأشخاص في إيران الآن ممن
يرغبون في شراء واحدة لأنهم
كذلك  باهظة الثمن
سواء كانت عقوبات سواء كانت حربًا
، فإن الأشخاص العاديين هم الذين
يعانون حقًا من تداعيات هذه الأنواع
من الإجراءات الحكومات أعني
القرارات السياسية التي تجعل الحياة
أكثر صرامة ولكن الأشخاص العاديين
الأشخاص العاديين أعتقد أنه
يمكن أن يكون لديهم علاقة ودية مع
كل  البعض الآخر ليس لديهم حرب مع بعضهم
البعض هذه هي الأشياء التي تفرضها الحكومات